Indiana Jones half pit bull half
American Bulldog big boy a little bit of
a Spanish he was on the treadmill last
night [__] digging it
but this dog
not only does he poop on trees which
we've talked about and bushes and but oh
yeah he did it when we took him for a
walk the other night on the bush oh yeah
it disappeared so far into it I didn't I
couldn't figure out where to pick it up
there's definitely I picked up most of
it but there's definitely a little
Pebble somewhere in that bush he loves
to [__] on bushes and stick poop to
trees oh I remember yeah you know what
else he does dude she doesn't let you
kill bugs in the house oh I'm aware of
that too the last time I tried to move a
route a route a roach out of the house
and I tried to like pull him back to
like move him he snapped back and like
tried to nip me and I was like hey man
we're not we're not playing the biting
game here dude he he
you can try to kill a bug in another
room
and he somehow knows it and runs in
all worried
yeah like if you try to step on a bug in
front of him he will jump up and put his
paws on your chest and try to push you
off away it's so weird it's bananas yo
dude try to try to kill a fly at the
house dude I've tried to I didn't even
try to kill the roach I just tried to
move it out of the house and he wouldn't
even let me touch it yeah he needs a
friend I think to protect I don't know
if that's it
he wants a little brother get him like a
little just just get him a little tiny
dog no he's yeah he'll love him no
he's not gonna like any dog that takes
attention away from him that's not gonna
happen he's the biggest baby dude he is
a big baby he's a giant baby but why is
he protecting the bugs I I'm so Milo
doesn't protect bugs he actually like we
have a video of him catching a fly in
the air and then with his mouth yeah and
then spitting it out and just patting it
back and forth he was like playing with
his food and then he just like stepped
on it and then he ate him
it was crazy yo I've seen dogs try to
catch flies with their mouth it's like
impossible oh he he caught him and then
he spit him out and then he just like he
was like he was like yeah yeah you like
that tell your friends and then he just
poof and then he ate him was the fly
alive when he spit him out oh yeah
tell your friends he should have left
him there with a sign and put his head
on a spike yeah like come around this is
what happens to people around here yeah
I was like Milo could you not and he
just looked at me and he was like I'm a
good dog yeah yeah yeah but now he like
he doesn't even notice the bugs in the
house anymore there's so many more bugs
in this house just because like there
are a lot more bugs here in the desert
yes they came out of crickets I did find
however I squished killed baby cricket
in the house the other day and Milo
walked up to it and sniffed it and I
pushed him away and he snapped at me and
he was like this is my and I was like I
was like is that your kill he's like
yeah it was it's a but it's okay for me
bugs they're healthy
a hundred percent a cricket is healthy
to eat I mean yeah we've eaten crickets
before yes 100 of cricket is healthy
yeah yeah but so look dude depending on
which one a cockroach is healthy to eat
gross I ate one I tell you oh I I
remember Were You There When I had that
well yeah
oh yeah I was there for everything
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]